remember
foreign
everybody
it is a great pleasure to welcome you
here
at the Natural History Museum in Berlin
and for those of you who are online
welcome it is a wonderful place which
you have to come to someday if you
haven't been to
we're coming to you live from Berlin
tonight's topic is rethinking cities
it's quite interesting to look at the
history of the city and what a city
means what is an urban area mean where
do we live how do we live
why do we live in cities is it a choice
is it not a choice and what does a city
mean today what will it mean into the
future
it has been a place where one gathers to
find opportunity to find friends to
learn to have opportunity
will it stay that way over the next 50
years
we have a great program tonight for you
a dialogue between three amazing
individuals and this is part of the
Berlin science week
this is providing a forum for scientists
science-driven organizations
and others to engage with the public
share insights into current topics
discuss Grand challenges and for us to
Envision the future together
I'm here hosting my name is Chris
lupeman I have the privilege of being
the head of the foresight the Strategic
foresight team within the Office of the
President of eth in Zurich and we have
been a proud partner with Berlin science
week since 2017.
now many of you will hopefully tweet you
will Instagram we have our hashtags we
have our handles or however you want to
call them please feel free to do that
during this next hour in a bit
now this event is part of eth zurich's
re-thinking living program we have been
trying to understand many aspects of
life and living in all sorts of ways we
are all feeling massive changes across
just about every aspect of Our Lives
climate change the destruction of
biodiversity so coronavine is pandemic
the technological disruptions present
threats but they're also opportunities
and they're an opportunity for us to
look at these as challenges
not to think them away but to look at
them actually right in their faces
rethinking leaving rethinking living
convenes scientists industry experts and
outstanding Global thinkers at various
events around the world it's a program
which we continue to do now now tonight
is an event which is a
co-sponsored of nfuels presented by eth
Zurich in cooperation with enhanced the
enhanced collaboration and enhancer
represents a new alliance of research
intense universities it drives
responsible societal transformation I
have to read this one because I'm sure I
get this one right you know this is
right
drives responsible societal
transformation inspires and pushes for
the development and utilization of
science and technology for the benefit
of society turning Global challenges
into meaningful opportunities to
something which we all can't take quite
seriously now
this event is also part of Zurich meets
Berlin and I encourage you to visit the
Zurich exhibition downstairs in the
dinosaur Hall how can you not I mean if
you had to walk through to get here so
stop and check it out in particular we
would really like to invite you to stop
at our exhibition from the eth Zurich
called material shapes the ages I never
imagined that I would see steel that
floats and this is what you see right
here is metal which floats and that is
pretty amazing actually and to think why
and this is in the exhibition Simone
who's our curator here in the front row
we very glad to share with you more
insights about the exhibition or on your
way out or downstairs or even tomorrow
to check it out so with that I want to
thank you Simone
now our time together will be 60 minutes
plus or minus maybe a little bit longer
depending on how nervous you all get and
if you want to leave you know I mean we
know we'll leave but I'm going to ask
our three speakers to come up
and we're going to have a bit of a
dialogue and then you will also have a
chance to ask questions now they're
little cards that were on their tail on
your seats you might be sitting on them
I don't think every single seat had them
if you don't have a card and maybe you
can borrow one from your neighbor but
hold up the card at one point and we
have a microphone to be running around
and I'll ask for different people to ask
one question
I'll just repeat that tiny bit of
instruction will ask you to ask one
question
and we've all been at things where the
question turns into a half hour
commentary and I'd rather it be one
question now
um after then we will then have a
continued dialogue between all four of
us and you so
are we ready
oh come on
here we go are we ready for this let's
rethink cities there you go excellent
now
much much better
so our first guess I need a little bit
of cue the music
our first guest tonight
is um Jennifer
is a wonderful human a detroit-based
strategy and research professional who
works on the social impact field at the
intersection of social resilience
stakeholder engagement and
organizational Integrity responsibility
and risk and Jennifer is also an at
alumni and a founding member of the HS
Circle so welcome Jennifer come on up
[Music]
next thank you next we have Catherine de
Wolfe Catherine is a professor of
circular engineering for architecture at
dth Zurich and she conducts research on
the digital Innovation towards a
circular building built environment
and she likes to travel through time
when it comes to building materials
we're going to hear a little bit more
about that I found it quite intriguing
when she gave us out so Catherine
welcome let's go for a welcome come on
up
and finally we have Anna Marie wickmans
she is also and I say also come back
down in just a minute a civil engineer
in architecture and professor at the
department of architecture and planning
at the ntnu in Trondheim Norway she
develops and leads European Innovation
projects a guide cooperation between
public and private sectors and other
societal stakeholders to make cities
transitions to climate neutrality more
inclusive
beautiful and sustainable now how can
that be anything but a wonderful thing
right so Anne-Marie welcome come on
so I'm going to start with Jennifer
Jennifer Detroit
the place of your birth a city which has
gone through many changes and we were
talking about rethinking cities it's had
to rethink itself
more than once yeah so tell us a little
bit about that and how you got to
doing what you're doing now yeah
um well thank you that's that's a big
question but I know we have a few
minutes
um well so I've always been interested
in the relationship between people and
space you know people in their
environment and a lot of the work that I
did
um as an academic I now consider myself
as a pracademic I work more on the
applied sector but you know my work as
an anthropologist that that's my
background I'm really being also very
interdisciplinary was always looking at
how do we create meaning in the spaces
that we live how do we shape and
influence behavior how is our Behavior
shaped by our environment and a lot of
my work in the early days of my my
studies and my practice was around
looking at infrastructure and looking at
the relationship between people and
their built environment so I did a lot
of work looking at the targeting
behaviors of violent groups and looking
at
um and that relationship particularly in
oil and gas or resource rich areas and
it was through that work so my work in
Nigeria was looking at the production of
peaceful spaces within conflict areas so
I was really fascinated about how people
in areas where they're maybe
under-resourced or highly resourced but
what is how do we create the spaces
within that particularly within Civic
society and what's the role of of
Corporations what's the role of
organizations different parts of of
non-state actors really as through that
work I just started really getting
involved in working with organizations
to create help them engineer and develop
a deep understanding of the human beings
behind the spaces that they work and
really bring that into
strategy and into engagement and into
shaping and building more meaningfully
and engaging more meaningfully in a way
that benefits us as a collective and so
when I think talk about social impact I
talk about that aspect of how are we
going to address these Social Challenges
with really Solutions across different
stakeholders and I feel like Chris so
much of that work on like critical
infrastructure and the relationship
between human beings and their
environment has all led me to this point
of where do I want to be in a city where
I can bring all that
to all that understanding together
exactly and for me it was all about
Detroit because for me it's Detroit
where you were born yeah it was it was
the area but I never thought you know I
actually never thought I would be able
to move back my work was very much
International largely across the global
South and I just thought most of my work
would be out in a global community and
then you know I don't know I think
everybody knows I'm about to refer to
but you get that little voice in your
stomach or in your head and it's kind of
whispering to you
should go off and do this and there's a
little Detroit whisper that started
emerging in 2018 I looked at my husband
and our two cats and I said you guys be
up for this and um and and the idea was
what did the cat say you know my cats
are Swiss so they were really skeptical
um we we picked them up while we lived
in Switzerland they were they're still
skeptical
um but you know the idea was how can we
go in a time of talking about the
sustainable transition right where can
we go and be in a city we lived in
cities all around the world and we were
just consuming and then I had this
experience across the global south of
seeing how people against incredible
forces and challenges were able to
LeapFrog over that and build really
productive communities and so for me it
was Detroit felt like the best fit
because what an amazing opportunity City
that came out of bankruptcy in 2013 were
20 of the built environment has been
demolished it's vacant right it's an
enormous scale it's a scale the city is
very spread out so it feels at times
you're kind of says intermittent
development and you're ebbing and
flowing I thought what an amazing time
to go to a place that could teach me how
to Citizen in a moment of this
transition that we're making
collectively globally and I thought let
me let me go to the the most challenging
city in the world to do that that's the
most awesome opportunity we said to
teach me how to sit yes yes I think
that's a really wonderful yeah it's a
really wonderful phrase to pause right
along and to move because I think that's
really fantastic we'll come back to
Circle back okay
Catherine
you studied civil engineering
in Belgium
and now you're talking about circular
materials for architects
connect those dots for me well I mean I
studied civil engineering and
architecture already in Belgium so it's
one of the few countries where you can
really combine the two degrees and for
me that was always natural right to
combine civil engineering and
architecture I don't see the one without
the other and sometimes I cannot really
tell which one is civil engineering and
which one is architecture and in a lot
of practices and universities is very
separate
and so when I had to define a name for
my chair at eth Zurich
it was clear that it was going to be
about circular construction and that
would have been simple to call it like
this but circular engineering for
architecture was really what I wanted to
do because I'm in this Department of
Civil environmental and geomatic
engineering and I think it's really
as Engineers we are trying to solve
problems for a purpose right and so it's
towards an architecture that makes the
world more circular that makes us use
our resources in a more smarter in a
smarter way
um is really what I wanted to work
towards so um our buildings are really
built in a very linear way today we
extract resources we produce our
building materials we use our buildings
and then at the end of life we throw it
away Chuck it away so how can we make
this more circular in the sense that we
use our buildings as long as possible I
mean the building we're in is is a
beautiful example of this
um you can feel also the history and you
can admire also the construction
techniques from another time
um you can see the history we were
looking also at the the the bullets uh
holes that were filled in
um so
there is this this time component of
buildings that we have forgotten today
and and today it's very easy to say
let's just demolish and build something
new something bigger uh without thinking
about the impact that this has on the
environment right uh and and so this
circular thinking I wanted to bring this
back into both engineering and
architecture and bring these disciplines
together and Jennifer was also
mentioning about
um the social impacts and Behavioral
Studies and um we were just chatting
about her her background as an
anthropologist and I mentioned to her
that one of my first hires in my lab was
an anthropologist so in my lab I have
Architects and civil engineers of course
but I also have computer scientists I
have anthropologists I think it's really
important to connect different
disciplines because we have very complex
issues to solve today so in a way you're
sort of rethinking cities by rethinking
a mindset of segregation to a mindset of
collaboration exactly I think it's very
important to connect uh people with each
other and connect disciplines with each
other to solve the most pressing issues
of our time so we're going to come back
to some of your research which you're
working on I'd like to hear more about
that but before we do that I'm going to
go right next to you because it happens
that we have two
Belgian civil engineers
here tonight
but and Marie you have taken at a very
different path
to land at what you're doing so tell us
a little bit more about what you're
doing and how you got there sure
um well we started in the same place
similar education maybe like 30
kilometers from each other more or less
I very quickly figured out that
I studied architectural engineering but
I didn't really want to become an
architect
I did one year of political science
um I thought it was a bit abstract
and I did something in Building
Technology I liked working with people
better
and then
um
I guess I I you know I started okay I
thought I could teach a bit I could work
with students Etc and the first Workshop
I had to do was I was terrified you know
what am I going to do with all these
people
um are they going to listen to me so not
just presenting but you know working
together
and then I figured out that I really I
loved doing that I loved bringing people
together and the more different
disciplines the better who started out
with Architects and engineers and then
we started adding economists and
sociology and and filmmakers and
everything else
and um I thought well
we do that with students we have these
experts in teamwork courses but we could
also do that in Innovation projects
right so we started to create projects
where we put professionals
um practitioners policy makers together
and societal stakeholders so citizens
communities and choosing an area in the
city and just do experiments locally and
and figuring out what people want and in
need
um and then we started to take that and
inform policy and politics based on it
so kind of the circle is complete I do
some of the political science and some
of the architecture some of bringing
people together so now
um
we have this big craft creating
actionable Futures Urban movement where
we bring cities together that yes they
want to become climate neutral but they
want to do this in a way that makes them
also more beautiful and inclusive and
resilient and robust and that base is
based on local communities and what's
already happening there so yes you need
to do the big infrastructure Investments
and the big political decisions and you
need to reduce and remove Etc but what
if you turn that around and use the
opportunity to find a more positive
future so that's what we're working with
cities on to learn from each other
because if you say oh you need to become
climate neutral
a lot of cities think well we're not
ready for that yeah we try but we can't
get there fast enough but if you start
to talk about working with local
communities maybe some Urban gardening
um looking at better Mobility you know
how can you walk and bike within your
neighborhood how is it easier to
I'm sorry to say I tried the Deutsche
Bahn
um
we're all aware of this team yes all of
us just I'm sorry but I I couldn't
manage and you know I'm used to working
with apps etc etc and it just it was so
difficult it was even not not available
in English Etc and then so
how can you just make it easier and more
attractive for people and just like yes
we want to do this this is part of our
identity and culture and so that's what
we want to do and actually after this
I'm going to Prague
um and there we are bringing all of
these cities together for the first time
some you know in vicinity that are there
some online and we're going to discuss
how can we learn from each other what's
everyone already doing we have cities
from Bulgaria and Romania and and
Scandinavia and turkey and you know all
across Europe
small ones like a few tens of thousands
and then cities with several million
people and they're all going to discuss
and and check what what is everyone
doing and how can we test something that
worked somewhere else would would that
also work with us and then where do we
go from there I think that's really
fantastic as you're saying you just have
to make almost make it easy to do the
right thing and I think this is
something I think Catherine with your
work I'm going to come back this way for
a second with your work is trying with
looking at digital tagging or tell us a
little bit about your work and how you
make trying to make it easy to do the
right thing yeah I mean what you just
said about making things easier really
resonates like you said with my work
because we explore digital technologies
that are used a lot in other sectors and
we bring them to the construction sector
to make circular construction easier
because I believe that when you want to
make an old model obsolete like I want
to do with the linear construction model
you need to make the you need to make
the new model more attractive right
easier cheaper faster more common sense
to do right and so what we do is we we
look at all steps of construction and
and buildings and see where we can
use Technologies like for example
machine learning how can we use computer
vision to recognize based on Google's
preview images which materials are in
buildings in what state they are what
condition they are and then have a
better view on which building materials
we could reuse in the future when a
building gets demolished we can also use
that to predict demolition we also when
we are demolishing a building we tag our
materials so that we can track and Trace
them through other future life cycles
right so we did that I think in the
beginning you showed a slide with a dome
on it that's a dome that we built on the
campus with a building that my students
disassembled entirely so this was a
two-floor Timber building that's in two
days my students disassembled so that
was quite impressive to see actually how
easy it was to disassemble this building
but then the tricky part is giving an
identity to the materials right and so
we engraved QR codes on the timber beams
and so now when you go to this Dome you
can scan the QR codes of all of the
elements and it gives you an a bit of
information in a database that says this
beam was previously in this building and
is now in this building it has these
Dimensions it has this properties this
is what the material went through and it
really gives an identity to the material
so that you can track and trace it and
and reuse it more easily in the future
and and it's really about using
technologies that we have today to make
it easier to reuse building materials I
think I'm going to add a couple things
you said easier cheaper faster more I
mean more beautiful more beautiful
healthier you know more more
oh no someone's balloon box bummer
and scared us all that's okay here we go
fine okay we're okay
well we didn't all duck yeah yeah no we
all like I'm surprised you didn't talk
no man you know I worked in Conflict
zones I'm good with a big bang yeah
anyway oh yeah more and more beautiful
is also a really big big important
factor for us as well and we see that
when you make more beautiful structures
more beautiful buildings more beautiful
cities it also creates an incentive to
keep the building right so I was talking
earlier about wanting to avoid
demolition
um I mean this building is probably here
because it's beautiful right and people
kind of like this I mean there are many
examples of beautiful structures where a
lot of Labor and craftsmanship went in
there and we recognized the value also
of beauty as something that Fosters
circular construction right and because
it's part of a mindset shift when we're
thinking about rethinking cities how are
you you think about those spaces but the
what does Beauty mean in the different
typologies of spaces and places
now
so making things easier
what how does that resonate for you with
what you've been doing with in Detroit
yeah so for me what popped up is you're
talking about that and and you were
talking about an app uh anime yeah so so
businesses right or even governments
right they they have this tendency
um especially when you talk about
businesses and they're working the tech
space and they want to work in the space
of City healing or city transition or
city solutions you know businesses have
a tendency to make a product they call
it a product they have users and they
have experience and they just throw it
out we see this with like the electric
scooters right electric scooters all of
a sudden one day there was electric
scooters all over our cities and it was
like what is going on right and before
not too long after they were very easy
to use but they became electric trash in
a way right just cluttering up and I
think when I think about making it easy
is thinking about one thinking about the
whole system so getting businesses or
those that are in the space of making
solutions for the city in in using
technology to interface with our
physical environment
thinking about going to those different
stakeholders understanding you know what
is you know what are the ways that they
move how do they understand how do we
make something I love your term
beautiful easy and beautiful but also
understanding yourself within a larger
system right because when the electric
scooter is entered in our to our
environment yeah you could jump on in a
zippy and it's fun but then suddenly
it's conflicting with other mobility in
our cities and our pathways on sidewalks
and how we move on bikes and it suddenly
became a nuisance right and that is the
product of businesses doing City
solution Solutions but not working
within the larger City construct not
working not looking at things
systemically and so for me that that
what when you say easy make it easy and
beautiful but particularly on easy it's
like thinking about your different
stakeholders thinking about how am I
going to make this easy for the city and
the governance of the city how am I
going to make this easy for I don't want
to call them users I want to call us
residents I want to call US citizens
because it's a different mindset and
when you think about it from that aspect
of citizenship and so when when
universities and businesses are working
in the space of cities how do we all
start to reframe our citizenship in that
space and how that influences the sort
of solutions that we make to make that
easy and to fit within our environment
smoothly and beautifully that's really
great so Anna Marie when you're some of
the projects you've been working on
across Europe
how does that resonate with you this
product citizenship
yes I was writing a talk because
basically it's some of the same thing
um we work with a lot of cities that
need to reinvent themselves yeah uh they
might have
um
started out in fishing let's say and
then became oil and gas and then you
know a lot of Waterfront cities have
this we like the water it's part of our
identity but it might also flood us soon
and so a lot of cities need to rethink
themselves and
um
this thing about it should be easy to do
the right thing but what is the right
thing that that's one of the challenges
so it's not engineering where you make a
calculation and you have one right
answer there's a lot of different
Pathways towards that goal and the whole
point is that we need everyone to be
part of thinking and testing what would
be the right thing here for our
community Yeah in our context with our
history with our local resources and
that is something that professionals
alone can't do so we need we need
citizens
reframing citizenship not as customers
exactly not as Citizens as they've
always been but as co-creators of that
future agreed
and that so how do we do that or how do
we so kind of sorry can you give us like
an example of how to do that when you're
rethinking your city well one one of the
examples is
um that there's a lot of municipalities
that by law or because they want to
invite citizens to give feedback on
let's say a planning strategy or if
they're going to redevelop an area you
have an opportunity to give feedback
inputs
now very often when there is this
invitation
um there's very few answers in the
beginning
and then
the more time goes by the more answers
you get and the more Negative they
become but by then it's too late right
so the more concrete and visual it
becomes the more negative answers you
get but then you can't really change
anything anymore and we worked a lot
with the municipalities you know we
organized workshops and citizen hearings
Etc and it's so difficult to get people
in or you always get the same people in
and but then we started to ask people
okay so what would it take for you to
get engaged because obviously it's in
your interest and they say yeah but you
know I'm not an expert you know I maybe
I don't know best or oh I don't want to
go there because you know what if I say
something wrong or I don't understand
then I can't ask so we need to create
confidence and trust and openness and
making sure that people feel that yes
I'm welcome there and I can contribute
and I can ask as many questions as I
want and they it doesn't matter if
someone already asked the question or
you know so it's everything is
legitimate so and how do you build that
confidence and that's where we work a
lot with arts and culture maybe to ask
different questions challenge people in
a different way and not just citizens so
the most fun thing is is to get for
example a group of Engineers technology
experts in a room and get artists to
challenge them by reframing what they do
yeah but and you know so that's like
getting people to think about not just
asking the same question over and over
again and doing the same calculation in
the same argument but reframing it
looking at it from a different
perspective together and see if we then
can find different answers or different
processes towards an answer can I
reflect on that really quickly
[Music]
you know in Detroit we're building a 30
acre Mobility Innovation District which
is you know aiming to chart out the
future of Mobility so in a way in
Detroit we're going back to Our Roots
which is fun
um but going to this aspect of how do
you co-create so what we're what we've
been doing is and this is really
fantastic because it's this public
private partnership so leveraging the
collective there's an aspect of Detroit
because of the road it's been on there
was an aspect for those that were living
in the city during its ups and downs and
largely during its Downs as a community
you had to really bond together if you
were going to survive and thrive right
so there is this indigenous knowledge so
I love you you pointed out this like
confidence right you need to know how to
Citizen and so in a way we're a bit
practiced in Detroit but here's what
we've been doing because we've had a lot
of new residents who've come in who are
in the space of just being in a city and
consuming
um we have multiple different ways in
which we are organizing hosting online
in-person groups we have QR codes that
we're putting on our neighborhoods so if
you can't or if you don't feel confident
to participate in a feedback session or
a user experience whatever you want to
call it session on the design of the
park or the where the structures are
going to be in this Mobility the
district or what's going to be offered
in the buildings are going to be there
how do you want to interact with the
space we're finding multiple different
channels and utilizing those to reach
the citizen right and and start to bring
them knowing that there are people that
have been in Detroit for a while who are
used to doing this and active and so you
get a lot of those same people in the
meetings but then how do you bring that
new and create that new sense of
belonging and ownership and Activation
so we're using multiple channels so not
just the face-to-face QR codes and other
sort of different formats creating more
casual settings in businesses you know
coffee shops and whatnot to meet people
where they're at and start to create
that Foundation of what does it mean to
Citizen how can I connect with my fellow
uh neighbors
um you know residents how can I yeah how
can I participate and the thing about
behaviorally is we work as a social
group so we when you put people together
socially it creates pressure to behave
socially so when you start to create
meaning on we are going to come together
did you attend that meeting are you
practicing did you take that survey so
we're using a lot of feedback mechanisms
in our community to create that social
pressure to drive people to participate
in these key decisions interesting you
know when you made me think of like the
different learning styles yeah because
different Generations need to be engaged
absolutely ways from media and different
learning styles yeah it's actually
trying to as broad as possible yeah I
would also elect them yeah I knew you
were coming
um yeah I mean I wanted to talk a lot
about
um a bit about the participatory
building of a city right
um and this goes a lot along the ways of
circular construction we often a
circular construction project is also a
participatory construction project where
we really ask the people that we built
for what they need and to even help
sometimes so for to give you an example
I um worked a bit for an NGO called
tazando espasos publicos in Venezuela
where the this is a friend of mine from
from my studies who created this NGO
she's from Venezuela and she's working
on creating public spaces with the
children usually it's for schools around
schools so she does this with the
children and the teachers and the
parents of the schools and the children
really are making drawings of what they
would like to see in the public spaces
and then the Architects are designing
something
according to those drawings and then we
really take the children with us and
build something with the with the so so
I was there for for a little time uh so
we we worked a lot with reused materials
more out of necessity
um but the children were really helping
construct designing and constructing the
the public spaces and it gave them a
sense of belonging but also a sense of
responsibility right so if you have
built a space or designed a space
yourself you also know how to maintain
it you know know how to repair it and
you also want to respect it so you will
tell your your peers not to to to break
anything or or have respect for the
public spaces right and that was also
part of the the model of it and uh we've
done this recently on another project
with my partner in Switzerland where um
they asked also the children of a school
to design the cabins in which they would
it's a school that teaches in the forest
so they need some cabins in the forest
and they design
um with the children also the drawings
and the children also helps building the
cabins and so on so it's it's also about
even even one step further help making
them help design and build our cities
yeah so that they really understand the
value of it it comes back to ownership
yeah exactly
ownership and whether it's getting a
community getting a city part again so
I'm gonna pause just two seconds here
it's really great to let you all know
both online you can put questions into
the chat and then they'll let me know if
there's some questions there and here in
the room if you have some questions does
anybody have a question already
if I I can talk to them all night you
know this is easy for me anyone have a
question all right so I'm going to ask
like two more times this is this is
going one square choice but okay so all
right so rethinking cities
when you think say 5 10 20 years
into the future with all of your work
how have we rethought what has happened
in retrospect if you look back
so it says that the mindset has changed
what has changed what process has
changed that we're looking back as we're
rethinking
uh and just describe that a little bit
if you can because I think I love what
all of you are aiming at I'm just trying
to but who wants to go first
go first sure I mean
um two things one is um
we started to work more with societal
readiness
you mentioned you know getting a product
or a service ready for the market but
what if you don't just think about
technology Readiness but societal
Readiness so how do you do that learning
and that creative confidence and all of
these things that's one and and that
actually that was taken seriously not as
a byproduct of or getting people to
accept something but as an actual Way
Forward uh the second is that we always
talk about you know you need Integrated
Solutions you need to take nature based
and circular and culture and identity
and everything together and then you
find that nice physical solution and
process that's going to make it work
well we don't have any way to assess
the feasibility or or the financial
viability of those Solutions as to now
you know every unit even within a
municipality every unit has its own
procedures its own indicators and it
just doesn't match so
what we are doing now is to make a kind
of impact model so something that helps
cities stakeholders to look across all
of these fields and see where do we see
the benefits what what do you get if you
put the nature base and the identity and
the language and the economy
together and you try to make a solution
that is good for all of them you know
wouldn't that be better than looking at
a compromise that's the least possible
thing that you could make it work to to
you know avoid conflict Etc so thinking
positively like if we put these together
we could do so much more rather than
just find the least possible potential
compromise and
finding that model or those models
finding a way to work across the units
in the sectors and to look at the
benefits of doing that it's not
something costly and oh we don't don't
do that here and it's time consuming but
no this is actually what's going to work
this is what's going to make it possible
to invest in it because it will be
cheaper down the line it will be better
for more people it will create value it
will make it more affordable it will
make it more profitable yeah but then we
need to start to work like that and
don't say oh no that's not how we do
things here or we can't do that because
we have these and these regulations so
we need to stop thinking that oh this is
blocking us and just do it and then find
a way to convince the investors and the
politicians too yeah this is actually
better for us
great so 2040 you're looking back
Catherine
well when you asked a bit what does it
mean
read it on what we just said uh before
and I was thinking what about
reconnecting cities right we talked a
lot about different people different
disciplines and participatory
architecture and I was thinking we
talked about things being easy for
example we talked about apps being
making things easier and when I think
about apps that really were successful
on a business side I would say
it was about connecting people right
like let's say Airbnb for example was
connecting people that had a an
apartment with people who were looking
for one Uber is also kind of matching
people who have a car with someone who
needs a ride so
when we rethink our cities we should
rethink the connections between the
people right uh how how do we connect
with each other how do we connect across
different uh disciplines across
different stakeholders uh and and and
this is when when we talked about
citizenship for example and about
bringing the users also back into the
design and construction process it's
also about connecting people in the end
that's cool I like the rethinking
connectivity exactly at the end of the
day this is what this is the glue and
the neighborhood that you're talking
about that social pressure it's like
connected you know there's a connection
obligation or within your cities of your
work with Innovation trying to get folks
to connect again that's a really great
point
2040 looking back well
I have a real challenge in the cities
and I think I've thought a lot about you
know how does Detroit it's so unique how
does it relate to the rest of the world
in the city landscape right and I think
across cities and it goes back and it's
gonna be my drum beat but I want
everyone to walk out of this room
knowing this
um is is this aspect of how do you
participate right um and so when I think
about 20 years down the road we are so
conditioned um to just consume in our
cities right
it took me to get to my 40s until I
participated in a city council meeting
and and I'm shocked I'm a highly
educated person who's worked on societal
resilience who's worked in the built
environment and yet it took me a while
before I actually started participating
in a city interesting and so and I when
I've been participating those are really
tough spaces to participate in they're
not designed for us they're not designed
for the citizen they speak in coded
language their meetings are at you know
times where everyone's working so for me
I want to rethink like even City
governance right so in 25 years 30 years
how have we not only created more
participatory culture where you take it
as a responsibility to be informed to
participate to connect but also we've
made it easier within government to meet
people where they're at so what is the
redesign of how we organize in
government and governance that needs to
take place
um that's that's my hope and that's my
Pursuit that's that's really great for
the show of hands how many of you have
attended a local reminder a local city
government meeting like just put your
hands up really high yeah yeah let's see
it right so it's about
percent yeah
interesting I mean it's your call to
action after this meeting go to your
city council meeting go to one of them
oh man
piece of homework right yeah they take a
piece of homework away and action
homework that's um
that's really good so societal Readiness
building confidence rethinking
great themes for us and I'm going to
come back to you soon who has a question
I know there's a class in here there's a
whole class of students I'm expecting at
least three or four questions from you
otherwise I'm gonna be really
disappointed so we have one two three
right here so Nina's going to give you
okay
it should is it on yeah thank you
um yeah great panel uh thank you so much
um I have one question about you were
talking about connecting people and I
was wondering
um in cities you very often also
experience people that are disconnected
and you were talking about the design of
fostering active participation of
citizens how does
how does that keep in mind the people
that are disconnected and thinking about
minorities here specifically I live in
North Korean so I know that people there
are very much it's a very thriving
neighborhood but people are very much
disconnected when it comes to decision
making of what their City should look
like in the future and are there any
ways of trying to embrace them in a
better way yeah so I'll I'll have a few
thoughts on this um I think it you know
if you think about the city as a network
right and we think about as a network of
also associations so I'm a leader in my
community I'm on the board of my
neighborhood association and one of the
mandates that I take in my neighborhood
association level because we actually
Detroit
um is 80 black and then the rest of the
20 of the citizens are a mixture of it's
actually very quite diverse um so we
have a large we have the largest Arab
American community in the United States
um we have you know just very diverse
groups and in my community we have a
very strong Latin American community so
people with Origins from Mexico and they
felt they've expressed the same thing so
what what we've done on what I think in
terms of our approach for that and I'd
love to hear if other of my panelists
have thoughts on this is
um we've reached we've taken as a
mandate so created local hyper local
leadership and started to educate and
started to create a safe space what does
it mean you know what's happening in the
city so a lot of people the reason why
they don't get engaged they don't know
or they don't feel like their voice or
their things matter we talk about one of
the things I actually have it on my
phone there's this app that we use in
Detroit called improve Detroit and I've
gone out and used this within my
community to educate it's an app that
where you can report if you see a
pothole or any sort of issue that is I'm
an anthropologist so I'm always bringing
an artifact
um yeah so so you know helping helping
bridge the gap between citizens to give
them tools where they can start to see
and they can start to be engaged and see
that their voice does matter so what are
entry points that you have in your
community is there a certain app or some
sort of service that you can and bring
to your community start to host
communities show them that this is a way
that they can be engaged and actually
the way that they can have ownership
they can have a sense of agency because
when you talk about communities that are
maybe disengaged they don't have they
lack the confidence there's usually
something around
self-efficacy I don't know how to do it
sense of agency I don't have the power
to do it and and Bridging the Gap and
showing you know I got other artifacts
you know showing that the survey that
they took on the design of local park
their feedback actually mattered and
that feedback led to you know a
different design decision so we take as
a Community Association with working in
a community with uh under you know
historically underrepresented or
marginalized groups we try to not only
expose them to these tools and resources
but also show them when their
participation makes a difference and
that is such an important aspect of
closing that Loop great yeah that's a
great response Emery were you I saw you
were writing a bunch of comments sorry
you know it's just a teacher in me I
can't yes yes let's say the short answer
would be what she said okay good all
right in Norway we have a program called
I was thinking about how to translate it
um you could call it neighborhood boosts
but left it it means boost but also
promise oh and it's that really like a
local community and then going in and
working at with the local resources
people and that could also be because a
lot of people don't have an app or even
a cell phone so yeah it could be a local
library or a community center or a cafe
so where do people meet yeah and if
there's no meeting space how do you
create one where you see that people
would would be it would be easy to to
for people to go in and have a little
talk have a coffee have a waffle
something and you know talk and build
around that and by being
present the proximity locally
you Maybe not immediately but people
will be curious they will start by they
will talk over a cup of coffee and
you'll find all of those like Hidden
Treasures you know a lot of local
resources and knowledge you know being
expert at your local community that you
didn't know and so we have these
programs and then we have the climate
programs and until recently you know
they haven't interacted with each other
so in some neighborhoods you have the
climate programs with the energy
efficient buildings and and then the
networks Etc and then you have these
neighborhood boost programs and what we
started to do now is well what what how
would you combine them
um between Municipal units in one area
with vulnerable communities so how would
you and then it's often it's not about
the big energy infrastructures but it
could be about sharing Solutions
sharing in time or sharing a space using
something in a new way circularity
reusing something or just finding a new
function for something that is no longer
in use so those kinds of things doing
small local Urban Gardens where where
people can meet
and in that way contribute to classical
and then people think yes okay so what
we do matter absolutely yeah
that's the feedback go ahead I'm sorry
yeah I just wanted to and also one one
elements that I consider something to
reach out to as much people as possible
is also education and not just in the
sense of what we're doing at University
but also from the very early ages at
school to give the children a sense of
uh agency right and
um and so I'm thinking of school
education but also
um you mentioned filmmakers in the
beginning through films and through
images we we consume a lot of images
these days and this is how we
communicate so I think it's also
important to bring the message across
about where to find these actors of in
my case reuse where can I find reuse
materials to build something with that
would be cheaper than buying something
new
um and and I I strongly believe that
images is also a way to communicate with
a lot of people at the same time so
education and and films have also a role
to play I totally hear that I think all
of you are talking about some somehow
building vocabulary
that a community also feels that they
can use becoming familiar with that the
other thing maybe thinking about is
listening not just to voices but to
Whispers
um
How Can You Hear The Whispers
that are in the room or and and that and
The Whispers may just be an expression
like they'll work on someone's face
right so you have to be you have to be
present you have to be present in order
for that to happen and this is I think
what you're saying there so there's
another question here I believe
have one here and then we'll go up front
and then there's one on the very in the
back rows we got three four all right
yes ma'am hello thank you
um a nice discussion thank you very much
uh my question is about
um the feedback people give and
um
so about change when there's a new
implementation and it affects people's
they detail day-to-day lives
um most people are against change and
they give bad feedback and even though
it's good for the future they most might
care about their daily lives and find it
as a negative effect on their lives an
example I have
um in the junction our building there
was a new bike lane that was painted a
couple of weeks ago and we just realized
they painted it back to the car road
again like the bike bike Road was gone
eliminated by examples were down no
longer welcome yeah and I imagine people
were complaining and maybe they decided
back to change it back so I was thinking
what to do about
complaints or people how can we give
this vision of and this discomfort with
change and how to be ready for the
change which is either bringing or
inevitable yes okay great okay it brings
us back to the your term of societal
Readiness right uh I think it's
in your example did people from the
neighborhood paints back the the thing
or you know the city okay okay
so that could also that also happens
yeah yeah I mean I mean there is a I'm
from Brussels and they're um they they
try to make the city center pedestrian
again uh and in the beginning there was
a lot of complaints about it as well the
shops were like oh if we cannot come to
my shop with the car anymore I will lose
customers and so on uh this this black
resistance to change but then of course
what happens is that when you make the
area of pedestrian it makes it more easy
nicer to walk around and of course you
have more people coming to your Shops
and and it kind of changes a bit the
Dynamics in my opinion for for the
better uh having a bit less cars in
cities is and a bit uh more soft
Mobility is always a plus in my opinion
but um but
I think it comes back to what I just
said before the question education and
films is something that will really can
help
people understand why the change is
positive for them and also kind of
communicating the benefits for people as
well uh of the changes that we want to
bring and and I think yeah communication
is really important in that sense I
totally hear that and what's interesting
with this I don't know this exact
example
but in cities there are layers of voices
yes I think this came to your question
before as well a little bit about those
who are who have who have no voice
but those who have a bit of a voice and
those are Extremely Loud
and sometimes the loudest voice is not
always their most rational yeah right
and how do we mediate between what's
good for short-term medium term and long
term Yeah because sometimes there's
short-term needs I'm going to interpret
your question a little bit here
short-term needs versus long-term
benefit
this is a very human challenge
to begin with any any thoughts on that
one a short term long term
we're rethinking cities well just really
quickly so the way we move the way we
build the way we power the way we eat
the way we live life is anchored and
highly like deep habits and deep
mindsets
um beliefs and so I I always see this
with governments but especially
companies they underestimate how much
work you need to do to really shape
understanding and help people come along
and also let me just remind us
government is what we do together so
it's it's always difficult and choppy
and sometimes you make an intervention
and you've done all the groundwork and
then you know we have to roll it back
for a little bit so we have to also have
a little bit of resilience that you know
just because something maybe fails or
doesn't get the buy-in that you hope
that maybe that's a part of the process
of going to this aspect of short medium
long so maybe sometimes a stumbling that
we experience in initial even if we've
done everything right it's just a part
of the journey for us to start to become
familiar so even if we have to walk it
back doesn't mean we can't go back to
the drawing board and go forward so
taking a longer perspective you know
businesses work so often and especially
startups fast fast fast I'm encouraging
a lot of us to like slow down right slow
it down slow down your expectations slow
down you know I know we have to quickly
make the transition uh to a more
sustainable City and living but we do
need to slow down a little bit and and
invest a lot more on the front end
around understanding storytelling
bringing people around so that we don't
hit as many roadblocks yeah okay and
maybe just say something about the short
term long term as well the way decision
makers are usually politicians and they
have their mandates right yeah and it's
very popular to build a new bridge but
less popular to maintain an existing
Bridge already and this kind of brings
us to the problems with infrastructure
that we know today and that's kind of a
big challenge for for infrastructure in
the built environment they love to be
there with the circular for the cutting
the ribbon exactly not for using the
broom right this is all or yes did you
want to add something yes
um
we often talk about bananas so build
absolutely nothing anywhere near anyone
[Laughter]
say that one again the banana banana
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
any
anyone yeah because
so
um people will be against it because
it's changed but that's exactly where
the societal Readiness comes in so if
you've talked to people worked with them
so they know it's coming or that they've
been part of shaping what it's going to
look like what it's going to do and one
concrete example that I also think
answers one of those questions is the
one of the Cities we work with they have
a river
so they want to create this this uh
District neighborhood that generates
energy so not by solar cells or so but
they have the river so they want to put
a turbine in the river so that's going
to you know rotate and create energy for
the neighborhood because it's a nice
Heritage neighborhood so they don't want
to add solar cells and start to renovate
you know they want to do something else
so it would be positive for culture and
identity but then the river is also
being used by rowers sports groups
there's fishing going on so those people
of course they're against it and you
know what it what it's going to look
like is it's going to be noisy is it
going to be polluting Etc and it took
four years of talking negotiating
Dialogue on could we find a solution
that is actually good for everyone that
is beneficial and it took four years but
we found a solution and yes so the
energy experts and the economists and
the local communities the different
sports groups and culture groups and
everyone was involved in finding this
solution but we did find one and
hopefully the next city that has a
similar challenge will be able to use
this so they don't have to start from
zero so but you have to want to or
someone needs to come in and create that
space an open space where these
different interests can meet without
making it a conflict without raising it
to you know some shouting matchers or so
making a neutral ground where we can
meet where we can have this dialogue
where we can negotiate and find
Solutions together that's great okay
thank you I'm going to take this next
question up in front no you don't want
to take it there's one on the way back
there Nina with woman with the mask
and then we have a few questions that
here have come in online and we're
probably gonna take one of those but
we're gonna have your question first
we're going to do this question there's
one over here and then we're gonna
probably have to wrap up because we're
cutting close to the room's warm now
everyone's popping up the other one's
all right okay go ahead yeah hello and
as we talked about the mask it's
interesting because like we've been
through discovered stuff that puts the
Earth as a city
and how are you thinking about it as we
have this great Abyss in between our
cities in Europe United States and
the rest of the world and we had these
problems with the vaccines and all of
the stuff and as a whole the thinking
the Earth as a city
we can't just think about our own micro
cities our own micro problems without
thinking it as a whole because it's a
whole system and it wouldn't work
properly if we are not thinking about
and now the immigration we are having
this great problem because of wars and
this hailed
Abacus we have in between our world so
what are you thinking about it how are
you saying this thank you very much
so the world as a city I'm just I'm
going to interpret that and saying we
have the world we have one only have one
planet it is a massive system we're
disturbing it and this is one of the the
needs with the translation or the
transferal
of knowledge to become a more planetary
a better planetary citizen
I guess so what about the being a better
planetary citizens how do we see that
any of you want to come into this to the
question
oh I yeah go ahead I mean I um
it's it's a very complex
world that we're living in right and
everything is very connected
um
and I think what we've talked about and
this is about rethinking cities and we
talked about on a city scale on a
community scale and so on and I think
this is where
changes are easier to kind of make I
mean I talked about this example of uh
changing public spaces with school
children this is a very small community
it's easier to to go from a small
community and make a change there and
then kind of try things out and then see
where we can upscale it right
um I think
what we do need to do is
understand where we can innovate and
where we can go towards something that
makes this world a better place right
and uh one of and maybe I connect to one
of the questions was about uh this
interdisciplinary teams and we talked a
lot about connecting people about
connecting disciplines and so on so I
think it's also about communicating and
and
having exchanges and having a lot of
diversity in the ideas that we exchange
about making this a better place maybe
willing to do it I mean this is a key
thing it's a mindset to open into
exchange so my response to yours is
focusing on regeneration if you say if
you take a look at the work from Paul
Hawkins his recent book regeneration
what he says we have to put life at the
middle of everything that we do life of
all kinds not just human life but all
life I think this is something if we do
this and respect all life we begin to
think about rethink our cities and where
do we need to put life back into the
cities either through Urban regeneration
regenerative agriculture it's actually
looking throughout the entire systems in
which we're a part of and to me this
would be my answer to you back there and
saying look look at regeneration as a
keyword for the next decade because if
we don't do this we're sort of toast you
know as a species you know dinosaurs
lived on the planet for 165 million
years we might make it to fifty thousand
right so it's very interesting how how
that kind of like kind of works with
this synthesis so we have time for one
last question up here yes sir that's you
don't be so nice you got a cool t-shirt
so it's okay yeah what's your question
okay so my question is a bit related to
what Katarina was talking about how the
politicians always want to you know cut
the ribbon and make the new bridge but
also related with what Jennifer was
saying that we need to like for example
build new systems for represent uh
representative uh new new government uh
not in the government governance new
governments modules so this is my
question like I'm an architect and urban
planner and as a professional it's very
hard to see your place how how can you
influence that because I saw it too many
times very good activity number planning
is getting jobs in the government making
change and then four years later they're
fired there's a new conservative
government elected then everything goes
down and in four to eight years we have
to start again so it's like how within
the problems of representative democracy
that is the best we have and that we I
hope we keep how can we as professionals
actually influence this is it more from
the inside is more fun and outside is
more with communities more from a
technical perspective like what's got it
great question all the above yeah
totally there you go so I'll let you
guys take it well there's one I mean
Berlin science week's gonna love me I'm
an artist I'm an artifact person so
there's on the paper there's an article
in here new platforms for Wicked
problems you should read it it's about
the sustainable transformation and how
there's communication problems so it's
going to be hard right but I think it
goes into what I see in my work across
different disciplines and different
stakeholders I'm very interdisciplinary
so I work across different groups the
Common Thread that I see is people not
investing enough to understand each
other and really do and create that deep
understanding around how do these
different stakeholder groups how do we
approach them so if we just take the
interest of business you know a lot of
times business will come they got you
know they sell they got a solution
rather than saying to a city approaching
it from more of a place of curiosity and
authentic care of what are your
challenges where are you struggling with
access where are you struggling with
funding for you know and so really doing
the work I know we're all eager we're
change makers we want to pop Solutions
out we want to change the world that's a
beautiful thing but we got to roll back
a little bit and and meet each other
where we're at a little bit more and
invest a bit more and understanding each
other great answer
hey go ahead Anna Marie and then
Catherine yeah yeah it's
it's planners
um
one way is of course and a lot of
Architects are doing that now looking at
circularity and at renovating buildings
rather than just having these you know
new generic boxes popping up everywhere
and you see that
um say 20 years ago when you had a lot
of let's say positive energy buildings
but that were based on mechanical
ventilation systems Etc that never
really stuck with with Architects but
now circular Solutions renovating taking
these wonderful old buildings and if
they do have to be renovated then
putting new maybe wood materials inside
and creating these wonderful spaces that
is going on right now and that a lot of
Architects are working in this way we
can help to promote this but another way
of working is you know as Architects
we're trained to look across disciplines
across interests and needs it's
attracting the core putting that
together into new physical form or into
a process that is going to get us there
and that is something you can use not
just to create buildings or spaces but
in politics and in decision making in in
companies to you know why should a board
of a company only consists of economists
and lawyers yes you know why not
Architects or urban planners so I I
think as professionals we need to take
that space not wait until someone
invites Us in yes we just we take that
and more people should do that and if
more people do this as Role Models a
newer generation or anyone else will
also follow and think oh yes I've always
wanted to do that they're doing that I
can do that too yeah
it's a great one Catherine do you want
to add one or sure I'll add something
very shortly I think
I think way review
are
because then our profession
so right now
a lot of it is based on Star
architecture you have these big names in
architecture and they make big
sculptures I call them sculptures
because I don't consider it always
functional functional and they get a lot
of attention and and and
what I try to teach the students that go
in my engineering and architecture
classes is is really what do you want to
be known for for this crazy sculpture or
for having made something
made the society better made the world
better and with the examples that you
gave of of circular architecture or
regenerative architecture and I think we
need to change the way we look also at
our own profession uh by being servants
for a better City for a better world
better than a star yeah yeah thank you I
think all three of those are really good
advice it's a really great question and
I think um I want to ask one final
question of all of you because we're
just we're getting out of time and it is
on Monday I think we know what you're
going to say right but on Monday today's
Saturday I don't know maybe I'll say
something totally different it could be
I doubt it that's on Monday morning what
would you like all of us to either look
at to do to think about a website an
article an action what would each of you
ask of us for Monday morning
first is be hopeful I think there's a
shifting Consciousness and so start your
day with hope because look how full this
room is right
um it is happening right this
conversation this awareness is happening
and the second thing is go to uh get
involved in your community citizen so
are you in government are you a in a
university where are you in society how
can you start to become a little bit
more informed a little bit more engaged
maybe it's going to a city council
meeting
um or maybe it's something else I don't
know if every Community is different but
how can you start to Citizen differently
that's great
um
I mean we all live and work in buildings
right so on Monday morning whether it's
at home at work at school
um try to figure out who is in charge of
building the environment that you work
in and
try to find out if they know about
stakeholders in the community that they
should reach out to so for building a
more regenerative future for you to work
in to live in to learning right
um try to we talked a lot about
connecting people and try to see if you
can find these stakeholders in your
community and connect them with those
people that are managing and
constructing the buildings that you live
and work in that's great so take
ownership of your presence exactly yeah
that's great Anne-Marie
um
I would think I'm kind of opposed to the
in 20 years from now you know it's it's
far too long we won't make it by that
time
um
so
if you would just uh maybe not right now
we might not have time but if you would
just close your eyes and think
we're going to make it you know by 2030
let's say somehow we manage the
transition and we have these beautiful
climate neutral inclusive affordable
cities and communities and if you then
close your eyes and you think
what is that like what do you see what
do you hear what do you do on a daily
basis what do you smell
um and then think okay so that image is
what I want to see that's where we need
to go
and everything you you meet on a daily
basis then if you're in a meeting and
you think this is boring what are we
talking about why aren't we doing
something else
um or oh no you know why do I need to do
this activity I would I should be doing
something else so don't just sit back or
start to watch your email or start to
think of something else but just
say so hey I don't think this is the
right thing I think we should be talking
about something else we should be doing
something else and if people don't agree
maybe this is not the right spot for you
and should be somewhere else so not
thinking that someone else is going to
solve it or some kind of solution will
come along so I think a large majority
disagrees with the way we're doing
things now it's just that no one you
know wants to be the first yes it's say
or do something so but it helps if you
have that if you don't react against
something but if you have that positive
image in mind how is that wonderful life
going to be
and then thinking of everything that
happens and how it clashes with that
image and how you could get to that and
how to build how to build towards that
to build towards a positive
what's the beauty towards their beauty
yes that's really fantastic
so we are now at the end
thank you three very very much for a
really engaging
and Rich conversation on so many levels
so thank you very very much just give
let's give all three of our guests a
wonderful round
thank you
really
and I'd like to thank all of you both
here and online for choosing to come
here
at the Berlin science week
in our beautiful Natural History Museum
on Saturday evening to rethink cities
it is a wonderful thing for us all that
we have the privilege of being able to
do this
and it's important I think as we heard
tonight for us all to be thinking about
how we
become learn better how to be good
citizens
and to active citizens because we can do
this this we have the privilege Society
societal Readiness and how to
participate
so with that
let us now participate and
the city of this beautiful city of
Berlin
and a beautiful science week and I wish
all of you a wonderful evening and we'll
see you again soon thank you